>> COLE: I’m Chris Cole. I'm with the MySpace
developer platform. I’m a software architect
that works on the OpenSocial project and the
underlying technologies on that.
>> MALE: Could you give me a little bit more
information?
>> COLE: So OpenSocial is an open standard
for writing apps and accessing social data
from the various social networks. And we have
implemented a platform for third parties to
come in and build apps, and leverage the information
in MySpace to create new compelling content
that we haven’t created on our own.
>> MALE: Could you tell me a little bit more
about that little session that you made to
[INDISTINCT]?
>> COLE: Well, for us it was really a question
of, the competitors had some great platforms,
and we saw a lot of the great apps that were
being written and how much excitement there
was about it. But we knew that we couldn’t
come up with our proprietary solution and
get the kind of traction we needed. So in
various conversations, we decided that the
way to go was to come on board with the OpenSocial
platform and start leveraging what is going
to be done with the help of Google and hi5
and some of the other participants in OpenSocial.
And I think that’s really been a great decision
for us, because we’ve gotten so much buy-in
from the community, and people are excited
about the idea of being able to build compelling
content and then distribute it across multiple
networks.
>> MALE: So have you encountered any difficulty
to come up with OpenSocial? Or had there been
any war stories about OpenSocial?
>> COLE: It’s always a challenge. I think
the first challenge in MySpace that we always
encounter is how to scale things, and OpenSocial
was certainly no exception to that. So as
soon as we turned on within a couple of days,
we had servers tipping over and running the
firefights to try and keep the proxy servers
up. And it’s always a question of what’s
going to be the feature that’s actually
used--and you never know that out of the gate.
You only know that after people start using
your platform.
>> MALE: Do you have any tips and tricks that
you’d like to share with us and offers what
you do to use the OpenSocial...?
>> COLE: I would say make use of the apps
that are out there to understand what they’re
doing. And you know, just like back when we
all were learning HTML, you’ve used source
on them. You see how they function under the
hood. I would say if you are writing big apps,
your cache layer needs to be extremely important.
You need to local cache things, be that in
update or cookies and push information out
to the nodes so that there’s not the network
latency that’s, that happens when your pinging
back and forth between your app and the client
experience and the server.
>> MALE: So, what’s your favorite open social
not quite nice...?
>> COLE: I’d say my favorite has to be OSML
and a lot of that is because I’m writing
it. It’s a fantastic tag language and it
really speeds development up, some of the
demos I prepared, like taken app that’s
3,000 lines of code and turn it into 250 lines
of code, so it’s pretty incredible, some
of the cost savings in terms of development
and complexity you can have when you start
moving to OSML.
>> MALE: So, what’s the favorite app that’s
on the site?
>> COLE: Well, I have to admit, I probably
play Dragon Wars more than anything else but
I bounce around, you know, I’ve worked on
a Tic Tac Toe app for a book that we have
coming out. And, I don’t know, there’s
all kinds of them but those are probably the
top two for me.
>> MALE: Can you say that app [INDISTINCT]
or writing application for platform as, you
know, help the MySpace?
>> COLE: I think providing their application
platforms helped us tremendously. It’s really
driven some deep user engagement and now we
have yet another great feature for people
to come on the site and spend, you know, half
hour and hour, two hours engage with our content
and working with their friends, and that's
something that you don’t get when you’re
just to social network and people are simply
doing messaging and checking to update their
status.
>> MALE: So, I guess that’s kind of rebated
to the social but what are your thoughts on
the open web, like that there was a new feature
that that came out today, what was your line
to be?
>> COLE: I’d say, the big features that
we end up needing our security related it’s
kind of interesting to open the web and the
whole open-source movement in general is about
bringing things open and allowing more, but
the problem that we encounter is how to rein
in problems and keep the spam and keep the
attacks under control. So there’s a big
need for a little bit more sandboxing and
maybe some metadata controls, and to couple
that with say you cross site XHR request are
just a huge need in development, but it has
to be done in a way the balances security
and tighter sandboxing in the JavaScript models
so that we can disallow a lot of things, it’s
really important to us.
>> MALE: Is there anything that you need from
AJAX or OSML?
>> COLE: I think the cross domain stuff is
going to be really important. One of the early
failure points in our platform was the proxy
servers, they just were hit so hard, they
were tipping over, and you know, the farm
of 20 or 30 servers and you start dropping
10 percent of them and then it’s like dominos.
So having, having cross domain AJAX, it would
alleviate a lot of that.
>> MALE: Is there anything else you like to
add?
>> COLE: No, just go out, have fun, build
lots of apps and drive some great content
for our site.
>> MALE: Great. Thank you for joining us at
the Google App.
>> COLE: Thank you.